[موسيقى]
لا لا لا لا لا
انا مدى اعوام عرفنا صباح العربيه على
شعوب العالم من خلال رحلات سياحيه عبر
القارات هناك في الامريكيتين مرورا بغابات
الامازون واوروبا التاريخيه واسيا
بحضاراتها المتنوعه وافريقيا بسهولها
الخلابه
وحيواناتها البريه والقاره الاستراليه
اقصى جنوب الكره الارضيه باختصار جميع
اسقاع الكره الارضيه
[موسيقى]
في فقره سياحيه مميزه دخلنا مطابخ وجلسنا
على موائد عده واحيانا كانت الاطباق تطهى
في البريه قبل ان يتم اصطياد مكوناتها
تعرفنا على ثقافات من خلال طقوس مختلفه
كتناول الشاي في اليابان او من خلال رقصات
شعوبا واعراق تقليديه
الارجنتينيه وهنا تنزانيا الافريقيه وهذه
ايطاليا القديمه وهذه جبال الهملايا في
نيبال في برنامجنا الصباحي زرنا اهم معالم
بلدان هذا الكون وشاهدنا شروق وغروب شمس
خلابين لكي يبدا مشاهدنا يومه بنشاط
وحيويه في صباح عربيه مشرق ليث بزاري